de luxueuses villas enflammé c'est
maintenant malibu célèbre refuge des
stars américaines que le brasier ravages
des propriétés des kardashian et de lady
gaga sont menacés vue dr la scène est
horrible et sur le terrain c'est encore
pire
la vitesse à laquelle les flammes se
propagent a surpris tout le monde même
les pompiers des conditions extrêmes une
végétation sèche et les vents forts
attisent les incendies surtout et eu
dans notre champ pluie blâme la mauvaise
gestion des forêts et menacent de couper
les fonds aux gouvernements de la
californie depuis jeudi les scènes de
citoyens terrorisés qui tente d'échapper
au feu en empruntant des routes
encerclés par les flammes se multiplient
en tout près de deux cent cinquante
mille personnes ont dû être évacuées
la petite ville de paris des zones aura
été la plus durement touchée
90% des maisons ont été détruites
au moins neuf personnes sont mortes en
tentant de fuir piégé par les flammes
dans leur véhicule ou leur demeure les
pompiers sont toujours à la recherche de
disparus
feel de robbie les autorités craignent
que le bilan s'alourdisse
dans les centres d'évacuation on manque
de place c'est la consternation
ce résident dit avoir perdu sa maison et
son commerce en quelques secondes à
peine
ici un site mythique qui a servi au
tournage de près de 500 films et réduits
en poussière des scènes bien réel pour
ce berceau du cinéma ici jacques andré
charbonneau radio canada montréal